[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So I want to get
into this flow and interaction
idea with you, but I thought
maybe just start with,
just by way of a little
bit of background,
how does somebody get
into the prediction
business in the first place?
It's not like something I saw
and my high school counselor
offered me.
MARK ANDERSON: They didn't
tell you about that, did they?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, yeah.
MARK ANDERSON:
Because everyone says
you can't predict the
future, so don't study that.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
MARK ANDERSON: I was
always a science guy,
from when I was zero,
or five, or something.
And if you study
science, first thing
they teach you in seventh
grade is the scientific method.
And so what they
don't teach you is--
the hypothesis really matters.
They don't teach you
how to get a hypothesis.
And people have studied this.
If you look at the question
of who does great science--
not just wobbly
good, but great--
it turns out that getting
the right question, getting
the right hypothesis, is
about 90% of the deal.
Einstein had a great hypothesis
when he was 16 years old.
It's like, when I fly
alongside this photon--
which I can't do--
what am I going to
see when I look left?
And it's like, wow, that
question drove the world.
It's still driving
the world today.
So getting the right
hypothesis, and it turned out
no one taught that.
So if you're in science, in any
kind of science, at some point
you're going to start
creating experiments.
And you're going
to ask yourself,
why did that guy do
better than I did?
How do I fix this?
And the way to get great
questions, of course,
is through inductive reasoning.
And inductive
reasoning means you're
going to be looking at
a wide array of things,
finding something where there's
either a pattern broken,
which makes things very
interesting, or a pattern made,
where the next
big thing is going
to be in the same pattern.
Usually, it's broken.
And Isaac Asimov said that
about the words "that's funny."
And it's like, the
great words of science
are not eureka, it's
like, that's funny.
And that's totally true.
So as I came to
recognize that, I
had a kind of an
a-ha moment when
I was in my very early 20s.
I remember exactly
where I was standing.
And I was looking out the
window at a bay, water was out.
I just had this light
bulb going, it was like,
start again.
Reprogram your brain to
be really good at pattern
recognition, pattern discovery.
And if you do that,
that's not just
going to get you good
science experiments,
that gets you everything.
And it turns out-- for a lot
of folks here probably do AI--
it turns out that's
exactly the answer.
So almost everything in AI's
based on pattern recognition.
So it was a fortuitous thing
to think of that a while ago.
And I think that our brain
still is far beyond chips
and so forth in many ways.
So teaching yourself
to do this gets you
a lot further, even today,
than any computer will get you.
Except in the most
rudimentary things.
SPEAKER 1: And you want to
maybe highlight one or two
examples of things in the past
where you've looked at an area
and come up with
a prediction that
was maybe not an
obvious prediction
to have made at the time,
and turned out to be true?
And maybe reflect a
little bit about why
you were able to do that
when it's something so many
smart other people
seem to have missed?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
I think people miss things
because their funnel's not
broad enough.
They're not looking
at a lot of data.
They're looking at data
in their own field.
And that's a very
restrictive view of things.
So one kind of
weird one was I was
able to predict the
best-selling Christmas
product a number of years back.
And here were the things
that led me to it, right?
So I found this-- it's usually
these little stupid stories
on page 17, like two paragraphs.
There was something--
I'd gone to China,
I was trying to find someone to
manufacture a computer for me.
And they told me that
Samsung was unable to ship--
they could ship this, this, in
terms of screens, but not this.
They'd already run out of--
the education
market was-- they'd
already run out of these
big screens a certain size.
Pretty big screen, right?
And then I noticed that the
pricing change was happening,
where they had been
5,000 to 4,000,
and they were coming
down quite a bit.
And then AT&T fired
about 30,000 guys.
They're mostly guys.
And they're on the street.
And there's like a
big, big news item.
This is probably
in July, August.
Like, wow.
And I'm picturing-- and I'm
doing the micro economy thing.
I'm thinking, these
guys are all home.
And they're telling
their wives, I'm
going to get hired
again in months.
Maybe not true.
And what they're really going to
do is watch the football game.
But they have to stay at home.
They have to say, this is
exciting stuff, high tech
stuff, and it's going to
help me get a new job.
And then you ask
yourself, OK-- but when
they talk to their guys at
[INAUDIBLE],, and they say,
come on over for chips.
They're going to go like this.
Oh, how big is yours?
And he goes, mine is that big.
Now, the human body, like
Leonardo, it's about six feet.
So you could put
that all together.
And that was, by
the way, the size
that was missing from
the inventory at Samsung.
SPEAKER 1: Ah.
MARK ANDERSON: And so all
that stuff, plus the pricing,
plus the guys fired,
I thought, OK,
that's going to be
the best-selling thing
this Christmas.
And it worked out.
That's
SPEAKER 1: Really fun.
MARK ANDERSON: So that's
pretty disconnected.
It'd be had for a
computer to see--
hard for a person, but
hard for the computer
to see all those things that
are running together like that.
SPEAKER 1: I think
another prediction
you've gotten a lot of acclaim
for was seeing the oil price
collapse coming before
a lot of people.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
were the antecedents there?
Maybe remind some people
here what was the setup.
MARK ANDERSON: Sure.
So I have spent a lot
of time at oil prices
because it's a global tax.
It really is important to
understand the global economy,
which I care about.
So if you want to understand the
basics of the global economy,
the price of oil is right
in there in the beginning.
And after a while, you
learn certain things.
So I had learned, for instance,
that back 10 years earlier, it
cost about $14.35 to
produce a barrel of oil.
So that obviously wasn't
driving the price.
I learned that the
Saudi family had
$110 to pay all their
debts, because they
were spending so profligately.
And we saw it go all
the way up to 148.
So that made sense to me.
I learned that the
cartel, which had
had a rock-solid
grip on the price,
had lost its grip, which is
a really important thing.
It was a multi-year
project, but every year it
was worse, and worse, and worse.
They couldn't
maintain the religion.
Niger was cheating, all
these others were cheating.
They would say they do
this, they would do this.
So clearly, the cartel
was falling apart.
The price had been pretty
steady around $93, $95.
So you can picture it,
if the prior years,
you look back a decade, it
goes up to 80, 90, 148, 110.
And you can think to
yourself, the Saudis
are pretty happy about
this story so far.
And then 93, that's fine.
But at 93, it occurred
to me that some things
had happened that were new.
So one of the things that
happened that was new
was the United States
started making more oil.
And if you looked at the
storage capacity of our tanks,
for the first time
ever, Goldman Sachs
was building tanks
as fast as they
could because all
the tanks were full.
We were at 100% capacity.
We couldn't store any more oil.
Well, that's interesting.
That's a new thing.
And then, of course, fracking.
But before the fracking,
global warming.
So you say to yourself, well,
windmills, electricity, solar,
all these things are coming on.
And guess what?
This story, when we're
all gone, this story's
going to roll right on.
There's never going to be an end
to increasing alternative fuels
for whatever you want to do.
That's just a death
knell for oil, right?
That's inexorable.
No matter how you
feel about politics,
that's going to happen.
And then you put in the
final nail and you say,
oh, by the way,
we have fracking.
And it turns out, Joe, that
you have a million tons of oil
in your backyard and I do too.
Everywhere you sink something,
you either side drill,
or it's right there.
So the idea of how much fracking
would liberate was amazing.
And as soon as that
happened, done.
Those all together
led to the call.
And Prince Al-Waleed, who
has been released from
the Ritz-Carlton jail now with,
I think, a thing on his ankle--
still won't talk about it--
he said no one could have
possibly predicted this.
Well, what he means is no
person in the oil business,
because they were so used to it.
Often people get inured
to their own silo
are the ones who miss
everything because of that.
You have to be outside it,
just looking at patterns.
So I made the call at 93 bucks.
And it had that
history of decades
of pricing around in there.
And within very short order, I
think three weeks or something,
I said it would go
down to 45 to 50.
I thought it would take longer.
I thought it would take a year.
It was like a month later.
It went straight down to 45 to
50, and is kind of still there.
Now it's at 70, now it's going
to come back to 60 again,
I think.
But now it's a year or
two sitting down there.
So that call was hard to
make in terms of-- timing
is really hard.
It was an accident, but
the number was hard too.
Knowing that it would go
from 93 to between 45 and 50
and sit there, I can't quite
explain that one, I don't know.
That takes-- I must have been
seeing about numbers that I
didn't even register.
SPEAKER 1: Right, yeah.
In some ways, it's
presumptuous to ask
how do you know
to do this stuff,
because so much of our
performance is unconscious.
You've trained your own
neural net in a way that--
MARK ANDERSON: Exactly.
SPEAKER 1: --things emerge
that you don't necessarily--
MARK ANDERSON: There's a step
for me, which is a gut check.
I never will publish
something if I
don't get a gut check on it.
So I'll think,
that's interesting.
I wonder if that's true.
But if I don't really
feel intuitively--
that is the final thing.
I think there's a pool
of knowledge back there.
And if it doesn't match
against all that stuff,
no, there's something wrong.
SPEAKER 1: Hm.
So I think a lot of
people could get this idea
that you have to step
outside your silo
and take a broader
view to understand
what's going to go on.
But it's harder to put
that into practice,
because it's like, well, there's
a lot of information out there.
What do I do?
I'm a little curious
about your methodology.
Are you just constantly
voracious, and then serendipity
bubbles up?
Or when you're going after
a particular problem,
are you looking for what
are the adjacencies I
should be paying attention to?
MARK ANDERSON: It
applies to any scale.
So depending what
scale you use--
so we do this at the
office pretty often.
So you'll have a wide
funnel, and you'll
see something interesting.
And you go, let's
take a look at this.
And then you're
looking for patterns
that are more and more
local, until you finally find
something really interesting.
I met somebody in
the hall, which
I won't go into
the details about,
but we have a thing called
nutritional micro analysis.
We're looking at a lot
of nutritional questions,
and a lot of
drug-related questions,
and how the body works.
I was trained in
biochemistry, which helps.
And we found something.
I found something-- we're doing
some research on something
related to autoimmune
diseases, stuff like that.
And I found this biochemical,
and I was like, whoa.
It was showing up everywhere.
So let's do a
little dive on that.
So Denyse Davis works with me,
did a deep dive for a few days.
Big folder like
this, read all that.
Whoa, this is getting
more interesting.
So you can know nothing
at all, essentially.
It would have to be
biochemistry, about something.
But if you're very
objective about it,
and you apply these rules--
which are in this book that
you're going to buy today--
then it turns out you
can be not well-versed
in that particular field.
It helps if you
are, but you don't
have to be an area expert.
In fact, it's probably better
if you're not an area expert.
SPEAKER 1: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, and I guess that leads
me to another question I
had for you, which is, when
you're trying to understand
and make predictions in
an area, how much is it
about the numbers and the
nitty gritty quantitative data,
and how much of it is extracting
more intuitive or qualitative
patterns about what forces are
pulling on what directions,
and that sort of thing?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
It's probably both, but more
about the intuitive part.
It's more about
large-scale patterns.
You get Wall Street guys, who
are always penny up, penny
down, penny up, penny down.
I hate that.
That would be going
to Hades for me.
Those kinds of things are
artificial to begin with,
and they're not very
useful, and they're probably
being faked by the
management, so who cares.
But if you could say,
oh, this company is
going to lose its CEO
because of this, or her CFO,
or something's going to
happen to that technology that
will suddenly obsolete
it, that's a big deal.
And so if you see
those kinds of things,
you don't care about the
penny up, penny down.
So I try to find things which
are intuitively strategic.
That's why our name is that.
And then there'll be
things that even the folks
inside the company don't know.
They'll say, what
right do you have?
Who are you?
I'm nobody.
Just ignore me.
But you have that tool set
that gives you that power.
SPEAKER 1: One of the
things I was struck
by when reading some
of your recent work--
and this will lead us
into the work on flow
and interactions-- is you said,
I think last year at the FiRe
Conference, I've been doing
all these predictions in all
these different fields.
I feel like I've really
trained my brain up for it.
But I never really had
my own unified theory
of how this all works.
And the other thing you
said that I found surprising
was, you said, but
it never really
bothered me, because I was
still able to do my job.
So I'm just curious for you to
reflect on that a little bit,
and maybe what led you to
start thinking that maybe there
was something more unified.
Because maybe
there isn't, right?
Maybe there's just a
bunch of noise out there--
MARK ANDERSON: I hadn't been
working on that, really.
It hadn't occurred to me
that there needed to be one.
I thought pattern recognition
and pattern discovery,
that's it.
You can do anything
you want to do.
So I really wasn't
on the hunt for that.
It's kind of a separate story.
I think maybe in
this conversation,
we'll come back to
these two things again.
But there's flow and
interaction over here,
and there's pattern
recognition and pattern
discovery over here.
And as far as I was
concerned, there
was no flow and interaction,
and pattern recognition
was everything.
Pattern discovery.
But I had-- and I
think anybody who
tries to pursue this
kind of thought life
will have the same experience.
That's funny.
You have, that's funny.
And I had a "that's funny"
about 30 years earlier
when they first announced
complexity mathematics.
And I'd seen a
documentary on it,
and I'd read a couple of books.
And the idea was,
this mathematics
applies to arrhythmia
in heart attacks,
predicting heart attacks.
It applies to water dripping
out of a rusty faucet.
It applies to the
shape of a leaf edge.
And I thought, that's crazy.
There's no reason for that.
What's the fundamental
reason for that?
Because I wanted to know
what the patterns were that
were behind that mathematics.
Well, they'd had no--
if we today had someone
from the Santa Fe Institute,
and we've done this
with them, they
would say we have
three problems left.
One is we have no fundamental
theory, even today.
So, OK.
And I thought, these
are flow problems.
So I had that much of
the puzzle way back when.
And I had a chance
to do a retreat
with a woman who is the
president of the Santa Fe
Institute.
I said, are you guys
doing flow work?
She goes, that's possible, Mark.
That's possible.
That's all I had.
And then for 30 years, nothing.
And I wasn't worried about it.
It was just-- you kind
of pick up the dust.
Clues happen, you see
somebody, you file it away.
And about two years ago,
we were doing a FiRe,
and I had to say, let's do
flow, because I knew that much.
And we started working
on the program.
And we were working on
a different program,
it's called Undiagnosed, it's
a medical thing for people
who can't get a diagnosis.
And we had a dinner that night,
and the speaker at the dinner
was Murray Cantor, who's a
very famous mathematician.
And he chose himself to do
the Lorenz attractor, which
is the core competency equations
for complexity mathematics.
And after he was
done, it was Q&A time.
I said, Murray, is it possible--
now, I'd gotten this far.
I made a little
traction, because I
have two friends, one who's
a world expert on fractals.
We'd stayed up all night
in my hotel room one night,
and he's done the fractal thing.
He's like 10 to the
nth to the 10th.
It was a crazy number, just
dive down through Mandelbrots.
And these are also a
very important part
of complexity math.
So we argued for a whole
night and afternoon.
And I said, I think what we're
seeing is flow and resistance
to flow, like with water.
He said no.
They wanted to add--
they're electrical [INAUDIBLE]----
they wanted to add a reservoir,
which is possible.
And I said, no, it's just two
things, it's not three things.
So what's the other thing?
And is it resistance,
what is it?
So I came into Murray Cantor's
talk with that in mind
and I said, Murray, is
it flow and resistance?
And he goes, absolutely.
He didn't-- a
microsecond, right?
Now, this is an
interesting thing.
Here's a pretty
smart guy who knows
everything there is to know
about complexity mathematics.
And he just went, yeah.
So I thought, OK.
We grab him, we drag
him out of the room.
We sit with him over a beer for
90 minutes just pumping him,
like, what is this?
What's happening here?
He said, well, first,
Mark, you're wrong.
It's not resistance.
It's coupling.
In mathematics, we
call it coupling.
And I said, Murray, if
we call it coupling,
they'll think about
rabbits mating.
We can't do that.
How about interaction?
He said, interaction is fine.
That's fine.
So thus was born
those two terms.
And it turns out--
and Murray, we're
the first one to say,
he said it on stage when
we brought him to FiRe.
I asked him, I was interviewing,
I said, is this everything?
He said, Mark, it's everything.
SPEAKER 1: And I guess
I didn't realize it,
but you were saying
this goes back
to even da Vinci and people
like that were trying
to study what are these
fundamental interactions that
create all these patterns, so
there's quite a long history
of people trying to study this.
MARK ANDERSON: That's right.
So I was asked to do a
speech at the [INAUDIBLE]
Tech Conference, and they
saw this stuff at FiRe.
We'd like to talk about
flow and interaction.
And I said, great.
How much time do I have?
We spent about
five hours at FiRe.
So how much time do I have?
He said, 10 minutes.
No, he said eight minutes.
So eight minutes.
So Denyse Davis,
who works with me
and is doing research
on this, I said, OK,
but you've got to let me bring
my own interviewer, which
I did, and we have to rehearse,
and practice, and get this
into eight minutes.
And we get it into 10 minutes.
But after that was done, they
had a speaker's party, VIP
party.
And Curtis Wong was there,
who does Bill Gates's work
on his "Codex Leicester,"
which is a famous Leonardo.
And it's just been
released again, I think.
And I asked Curtis.
I said, what did you think
of that presentation?
And he said, Mark,
you've achieved
what Leonardo aspired to.
SPEAKER 1: That's
quite a compliment.
MARK ANDERSON: Cut there.
I'm done.
I'm going home now.
SPEAKER 1: Check, please.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah, please.
I'm out of here.
I'll pay.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARK ANDERSON: And
what he meant--
then I went back
and read it again.
And he wasn't just
shining me on.
That book is all about water.
And Leonardo used
to stand on a bridge
and watch the flow of water, and
the eddies, and the resistance,
and the self-interactions, and
the interaction with the coast
and with the rocks.
And he thought that that
was a fundamental thing
he was seeing.
And then he would say he
saw it in a woman's hair,
or he saw it in the clouds.
He saw it everywhere he looked.
So he was actually saying
something very real.
SPEAKER 1: So OK, so
this is probably worth
getting into a
little more detail.
So can you start with a
capital sketch of what
you mean by flow
and interactions,
and then maybe we can get
into a little more of what's
behind it, or some examples
where you see it apply,
and that sort of thing?
MARK ANDERSON: Sure.
I think everyone
has an intuitive
sense of both these
things, and it's not wrong.
So one of the most beautiful
things about this discovery--
which is what it is, not
an invention, a discovery--
is that it's not a
description of something
where it might be right.
It's not just my stupid
idea about something,
and maybe it'll
work out tomorrow.
It emerges from the world.
Just like complexity mathematics
emerges from the world.
So this isn't really
about the usual stuff.
It's really fascinating
because it is what it is.
What you see is what you get.
And if you look into
the biology, or botany,
or the biology of animals,
or how cells work,
or if you look into geology,
and how lava flows to the sea
and what shapes
result, or cloud shapes
and how they're
formed, in every case,
it is involving the
flow of something
and its interaction with
itself or with other things.
In every single case.
And so it's not
surprising that Adobe
can make fractal
mathematics that you
can use for all your drawings.
It's not because
it was their idea.
It's because this
literally is what's
happening with stone, and
with leaf, and with animals.
So the most exciting
part of this to me
isn't just that it's
universal-- which is exciting--
but that this universal thing
literally is coming and talking
to us out of nature.
And we're saying, oh, hi.
Got it.
Thanks for the message.
SPEAKER 1: And so are there
a few basic axioms of it,
or is it a meta pattern
that describes things?
Are there different
types of flows
and different types
of interactions
you find in different systems?
MARK ANDERSON: There are.
And so the fun part of
our conversation right
now is, welcome to early days.
We're about two years into this.
We've had very little
time to work on it.
We've published
one work, one book,
to help people like
you get more into it.
But literally, I can imagine
this going on forever
and people becoming
experts at this.
I can imagine the
consultants selling services
on how to bring this
to your company,
or how to bring this to
your programming techniques.
How to bring this into your
private scheduling problems.
It applies to everything.
And so we haven't done that yet.
And what I expect to have happen
is like pattern recognition.
I expect to see a
language evolve--
which we haven't done yet--
to describe certain
types of flows,
and certain types
of interactions,
certain types of
mathematical situations
when these things
are bunched up.
Sometimes flows are
good and positive.
Sometimes they're bad
and they're negative.
All of that work
has yet to be done.
SPEAKER 1: And you were
mentioning a fascinating thing,
which is, if you
look at the history
of high-performance computing,
including what Google does
with its data centers, and
these data flow algorithms,
and so forth, a
lot of that can be
seen as trying to figure
out how to trade off
flow versus interaction.
How much parallelism
can you get?
Where are the bottlenecks?
What has to be distributed?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
Well, you guys have some
invention called TensorFlow,
that's what it's called.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
So you know what I mean?
It's pretty clear.
I think to someone who's in
the high-performance computing
world, going back 30 years or
40 years, if you said to them,
what's your biggest problem?
They would say latency.
That's always been
the biggest problem.
So it's like, how do I get the
time-- squeeze the time out
of the communication between
these chips and the memory,
or the chips and the chips.
That will never go away.
And what they're saying
is, I have a flow problem.
I need to maximize flow and
minimize the interactions.
I need to have the number
of stops, and trips,
and gateways go down, and
the amount of flow per second
go up.
And that's it.
That's all there is to it.
Everything else is details.
So these guys have been doing
flow interaction since there
was a supercomputer.
And the same thing,
in a different way,
would be true if
you looked at people
doing more creative work.
So-- and I don't want
to offend anybody.
I think that there are
new types of chips.
TensorFlow is a new chip.
There are even more
different types of chips.
TrueNorth would be one.
[? NewEdge ?] is another.
So you're looking
at chips that are
called non-von-Neumann chips.
They're generally made to
improve pattern recognition,
which is good.
And in those kinds of
systems, you probably
see a situation where you're
trying to increase something
other than just the flow.
The quality of
what you're finding
will be better or
different, and that's
what you're trying to maximize.
So it's not just you
say, this or this.
And you can have a war
between these guys,
but the guys on the HPC side--
the high-performance side--
will say, we know
exactly how to do this.
We can scale this
up at Oak Ridge.
And the guys on the
other side will be saying
something totally different.
And yet they're both right.
And so there is a
long road ahead of us
in trying to understand,
not just one is good
and one is bad, but what are
the languages around this?
What situations in technology,
or in human relationships?
And you can imagine a romantic
relationship being full
of flow, right?
And very few but
great interactions.
Or you can imagine
something between nations
where the flow of goods--
people say trade is good,
the flow of goods provides
some cure against war.
OK, fantastic.
What we found very
early was that--
so let's go back a step.
When the global financial
collapse happened,
I happened to make that
prediction publicly.
And I think I'm the
only person to have
made that one and the oil
price collapse, which are both.
So no trained economist,
no trained [? economist ?]
in the world, according to
the "FT--" "Financial Times--"
got the GFC publicly right.
Wow.
That's amazing.
So they were looking
at the wrong stuff.
The Harvard-trained,
Stanford-trained,
whatever the heck it was.
And yet some idiot like me could
look at the flows of currency,
and things like that, and
global liquidity, and go,
uh-oh, we have a
huge crisis coming.
They just weren't paying
attention to that.
And we call this flow economics.
But it turns out
if all you did--
I think it's an argument you can
make that economics is broken
because of that,
and they should just
throw the tools away, flush them
down the toilet, start over.
Reboot.
And if they did
that, flow economics
is exactly what they should do.
They should be watching
the flow of power
through Russia, of gas
through Russia, of ideas
through a company,
of patents coming.
All these things are
flows, and they don't lie.
Generally, they don't lie.
So literally, you can tell
more about China today,
and it's a very
important question.
How's China doing?
You can tell more
about China today
and how they're doing by
looking at the flows of things
than by what you're being told,
because I can guarantee you
you're being told silly stuff.
SPEAKER 1: Because it's
not a closed system, right?
That's the point.
You see these things
go in and out--
MARK ANDERSON: The information--
yeah, the top part is closed.
SPEAKER 1: But
the actual flows--
MARK ANDERSON: But the
actual flows are detectable.
SPEAKER 1: This is very
topical, obviously,
the domestic
political environment.
We're thinking about tariffs,
and how much do you--
what's the relationship
between globalization,
and global capital flows,
and global flows of migrants,
and how much individual
self-determination each country
has.
MARK ANDERSON:
Well, in this case--
we spent a lot of time
on that question--
we know that Japan,
in post-war Japan,
invented a model which
we call infomercantilism.
It involves controls,
tariffs, structural barriers.
And then South Korea
picked that up, said,
we can do better than you.
Did exactly to Japan what Japan
had done to the United States.
And then China showed up
much later, about 2000, said,
we can do that
better than you guys.
Same model, beefed it
up, much bigger country.
So the model has been
around for a while.
And yet it's nothing like
what you see in the press,
You would never see anything
I'm telling you in the press.
So people on Wall Street,
or people in politics going,
free trade, and
Trump's trade war.
This is silly, because we
have three nations who've
built all of their economic
models based on blocking flows.
That's how they got rich.
They favor local companies,
they subsidize them,
they sell things at half
price in the global market.
It's a great way to get
rich if you can do it.
It works.
And then some country
tries to respond,
and it's like they're
creating a war.
No, they're not.
We're just seeing some
very feeble things
the same way that
everybody else is doing it,
or the other side is doing.
So it's a really big
argument, I think,
that's worth a
long-term discussion,
whether you can be an
innovative country or a company
and also be obstructive.
My feeling is no.
I think free trade and
free thinking are related.
Free speech is
part of this deal.
You can't have
great innovation--
SPEAKER 1: Flow of ideas, right?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
So my thought is this
is all one package.
And we'd be doing--
I think Japan's gotten over
this to a large degree,
and then South Korea's
still in the middle of it.
But we'd be doing everybody
a big favor in those
places if they let go
of the current model--
or modify it enough,
as Japan did--
so that, in fact, the result
would be that they became
more innovative in the process.
That would be a big
win for everybody.
SPEAKER 1: I remember the
famous economist, Bill Janeway,
gave a talk at--
I think it was last year's FiRe.
And one of things he said
that really blew my mind
is, again, if you
measure the flows--
I think that's one
of those takeaways--
if you can look for
any kind of system
and you can understand the
actual underlying flows,
like you say, that
might give you insight
you were missing otherwise.
And that just the cross-border
flow of capital, and loans,
and direct foreign investment,
and things like that,
even in the last 20--
starting in the late '90s
and early 2000s, just
this incredibly
dramatic increase
that led up to the global
financial collapse.
And it wouldn't necessarily
let you predict the collapse
timing, but it definitely
would have told you
we're in a qualitatively
different regime, which I'm not
sure you necessarily feel
in your daily life, how
much of this is happening, and
how much of the stuff around
me is owned by foreigners.
But they actually
tracked the flows,
we had moved into some place
that was very different
than historical norm.
MARK ANDERSON: He
was completely right.
One of the differences
between how--
so he and I agree on this, but
I was looking at it differently.
So he was looking at
flows, god bless him,
and I was at patterns.
So we'll come back
to that again, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARK ANDERSON: So I saw
a pattern in February 27,
I think it was, of
that year, where
all of the stock markets in
the world did a kind of a bump.
Like, all of them.
I mean, not all of them.
A lot of them.
Normally, you'd see Spain
goes down, Germany goes up,
whatever.
This is a daily affair.
You'd have to have something
like if someone shot
the pope, or some big headline.
And the "FT" caught
onto this, and they
were like, there's no headline.
They did a piece on it.
And I thought, yeah,
there's no headline.
What?
So there's a pattern broken.
There's this long
pattern of stock pricing.
Usually it's exchange
between countries.
Why would all countries go down?
Or almost all countries.
And it turned out
there was a problem
that no one had thought of.
And I won't go into
all the details here.
It is in the book
you all should buy.
But--
SPEAKER 1: Actually, I guess
this is maybe a good time
to remind people.
So there's "The Pattern
Future," talking about patterns.
And then he's also got "A Deep
Dive on Flow and Interactions,"
and we've got a couple
here you can look at,
and then you can
take information.
They're available to buy online.
But they're-- yeah.
MARK ANDERSON: With a
great quote by Vint Cerf.
SPEAKER 1: And yes,
by our Google's own
Vint Cerf telling you that
you should buy the book, so.
MARK ANDERSON: So it turned out
there was a reason, of course,
behind that.
It'd be like if all
the oceans in the world
went down a foot for about
three days and came back.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Like you said, it's
like, hm, that's funny.
MARK ANDERSON: That's funny.
So it turned out that global
investors on a very large scale
had been applying what's called
a carry trade out of Japan
using Japan's zero interest
rates, or negative interest
rates.
And the Bank of Japan governor,
kind of new to the job,
and he blew it and he
did a surprise rise.
And they all thought, oh, cover.
Got to cover.
And they all rush
back through the yen.
So you can actually see
the yen going crazy.
You see the Japanese government,
oh, my gosh, we screwed up.
And they're fighting
this yen, they lost.
They fight it again, they lost.
They it fight it
again, they give up,
and then there's
more to the story.
But from the pattern side,
that's what was happening.
And so I was a
little luckier to be
able to say some timing things
than Bill was, because he
was seeing a gradual change.
But this was over
three days, so I didn't
know when it was going happen.
I thought, OK, if there's
that much hot money
in the world moving that
fast on a dime, bad things.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Somebody's going to get shot,
something's going to happen.
The trigger doesn't matter.
What matters is
we got ourselves,
just as Bill described,
into a situation
we have too much hot money
flying around every night.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
because the other thing
he said that I think is
very apropos of what you've
been talking about
is, if you learn
how to maximize your use
of flow and interactions,
you're essentially trying to
achieve higher throughput,
or higher efficiency, which
normally is a good thing.
Like in high-performance
computing,
you want to have
maximum efficiency.
But it also creates
a form of fragility,
because you don't have
the same kind of buffers,
or the chance to stop and take
a beat, that sort of thing.
MARK ANDERSON: I re-read
his talk last night,
and that's his perspective.
And it's the one I
mentioned earlier.
It's the reservoir idea.
And it is true that
reservoirs provide buffers,
but they have other costs.
SPEAKER 1: Of course.
Inventory costs money.
MARK ANDERSON: So I'm not quite
a convert to that one yet.
I agree with the fact
that it does buffer.
I'm not quite ready to agree
that that's the only way
to get protection.
SPEAKER 1: Interesting.
MARK ANDERSON: There may be
ways to manage flows, which
can change based on
the world around you,
and that can cushion things.
If you're doing
just-in-time manufacturing,
like Michael Dell does, he's
not interested in building
a reservoir.
He's interested in doing
better and better at JIT.
And he does it.
So he's kind of the
proof case that you
don't have to have a
warehouse full of stuff.
SPEAKER 1: I guess
another area this comes up
a lot is in social media.
We have this ability
to send new information
all around the world so quickly
and react to it so quickly.
And that's obviously really
good in a lot of ways,
but then it also can
cause misinformation
to spread out of
control super quickly,
and it's hard to know how to
have one without the other.
MARK ANDERSON: It's pretty easy
to see, I think, that flows--
in addition to this
thing being universal,
we're moving into this
world in a more obvious way.
Just like that.
So whether you're
talking about computing
and having petabytes
of flow going by you,
there's a lot of talk
about flow computing
now, data flow management.
We talked about
flow triage at FiRe.
How do you just know what to
throw away as fast as possible?
Pretty important skill.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, when we have
all these sensors generating
so much information.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah, exactly.
So how we live in
a world is based
on flows and interactions.
It would have been
more theoretical
probably five years ago.
I don't think there are very
many people probably here
or anywhere else who now doubt
that their personal world is
that world right now.
Whether it's traffic
flows getting home,
or whether there's a flow of
data through their computer,
or the daily flow of work, the
flow in their relationships,
the flow of news through
their phone, it's all flows.
And the work they're
doing here at Google.
SPEAKER 1: And so is
your advice to start
to think about the work you
do, or your own life, in terms
of what are the flows, and
what are the interactions,
and use that as the
conceptual model for--
MARK ANDERSON: Yes.
I was talking last
night with a person,
and she said it's life changing.
Changed her life.
That's interesting.
So I think of it as a lens.
It's a new way of seeing.
It's not necessarily
revolutionary.
Everyone understands flow,
and interactions are obvious.
But they haven't necessarily
put it into a duality.
And they haven't thought
about it as a way
to become more efficient.
And last night's
conversation that came up.
Not only is it more efficient,
but it means less stress
for me.
Well, how do you avoid dying?
Less stress.
How do you avoid disease?
So if there were one word,
the occurrence of the word
stress in every medical paper
that says, "don't do this?"
So this is a pretty
important thing.
If you wanted to reduce
stress in your life,
and you only did one
thing, you use this way
of seeing your
world so that you'd
be more efficient and
less worried about it.
It'd be a good thing.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
That was something that
was very topical for us
at Google, because
we have so many flows
of incoming information.
Email, and alerts, and the
system going on, or whatever,
and trying to figure
out how to be maximally
productive while still being
interconnected to everything
that's going on
around us is something
we struggle with a lot.
MARK ANDERSON: Well, everyone
has written books and articles
about email
interrupting your day,
and people
and whether you should
or you shouldn't.
Sometimes it's good,
sometimes it's bad.
But it's pretty ad
hoc, in my opinion.
I don't think that the
science is very helpful yet.
And yet that's the
world we live in.
And you can add
another parameter
to that idea of your day,
which I think we've done.
So give you two examples.
We do meditation every day.
It's not very long.
10 or 20 minutes.
But I think that
that particular thing
is really important in keeping
the flow of the day high.
And it's been proven that
your productivity drops
if you don't take
a nap, or if you
don't do that kind of thing.
You guys have that down.
So that's an idea.
And then if you have the idea--
there are a lot of smart
people here at Google,
so this will fit.
Instead of having
prioritizations and lists
where you're going to do
this, and you do this,
and you do this, I
think it's easier
to have four or five
things that you're
working on at the same time.
And if the phone--
if the guy isn't
there, or the woman,
you can't reach
them by whatever,
you don't let that block your--
it's not a true interaction,
you just go right
into the other thing.
And so because you
got three, or four,
or five things
going all the time,
you're always at full speed.
And it's not that stressful.
If it's stressful,
you shouldn't do it.
But if you're just
kind of used to it,
you kind of build up
to it, it turns out
you can get a lot more done.
And you could think of this
from a computing perspective.
So if you-- people know
about messaging protocol.
They open API and stuff.
If you want to run a multiple
processor environment,
it's hard to compile problems
across many processors
if you're not just showing
video or something.
And that problem remains
in a lot of ways.
So how do you
distribute the problems?
It's a big deal.
But if you're thinking
about several things--
back to Windows threads.
There are solutions to this.
And so I think it's pretty
clear that the compute world is
behind us, human brains, but
coming in the same direction.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And it's interesting,
you mention
a lot of this renaissance of
these non-von-Neumann chip
architectures have to
do with how you optimize
and then break apart
these data flows
so you don't have the same
traditional bottlenecks, right?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
And reducing power consumption.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
And they're doing it in
service of pattern computing.
So it doesn't become
maybe full circle.
You had these two separate
worlds of pattern recognition,
and flow and interaction, and
it's an interesting insight
that studying the
flow and interaction
helps you do the
pattern computing.
And it may be vice
versa, I don't know.
Can you apply
pattern recognition
to flow and interactions?
MARK ANDERSON: So
I'm just talking
about the theory in general.
But I think that
if you've gotten
to where we are today
in these two theories,
then the really exciting
question that comes
next is, do they fit together?
And how do they fit together?
And I'm pretty convinced
they fit really well.
And if we were sitting
here in private,
I'd probably get myself
the point where I'd say,
the ultimate experience
in figuring things out--
if you really wanted to do
the best science ever done,
if you really wanted to do the
best compute designs ever done,
what you would do would be to
apply pattern discovery to flow
and interaction.
And if you did that, you'd
have this most amazing
intellectual experience.
True discovery.
SPEAKER 1: You think
that can actually
be bottled and put into a
real service of some kind?
MARK ANDERSON: Well, that's
a really great question.
Someday, I'll tell
you the answer.
SPEAKER 1: Hm.
There might be
something behind that.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: I'm
mindful of the time.
We can keep going,
but if anybody
starts having questions they
want to talk to Mark about,
as you can see, you
can pick his brain
on a wide variety of topics.
Why don't you guys go
to the mics over there
so we make sure we get
it for the live stream
and for putting up on
YouTube afterwards?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I wonder if you ever read the
book "On Growth and Form,"
and do you think
any of these ideas
were pre-saged there, or
maybe developed in that book?
MARK ANDERSON: What's
the first-- what's
the name of the book?
AUDIENCE: "On Growth and Form."
It's a--
MARK ANDERSON: I don't know it.
But there are a lot of
books that apply to this.
And many of them are well known.
They have to do with data
structures and so forth.
There are a number of books--
if you gave us your email,
I could send you some books
that I've been looking at
that are very pictorial,
and they're all about
this kind of thing.
I don't think they
were written--
I'm sure they were not written
with this stuff in mind.
You go back and look at the
flows described in these books.
You go, oh, I get it now.
That makes more sense to me.
AUDIENCE: It was at the
beginning of the talk
when you mentioned that the
famous inventor was talking
about how he observed
patterns in water and thought,
there must be
something fundamental--
SPEAKER 1: da Vinci, yeah.
MARK ANDERSON:
That was Leonardo.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a specific reference?
In what book did he meant
to talk about that--
MARK ANDERSON: The
"Codex Leicester."
AUDIENCE: Which one?
MARK ANDERSON:
"Codex Leicester."
L-E-I-C-E-S-T-E-R. And I
think it just came out again.
Bill Gates owns it,
but I think they
published a new version of it.
It's pretty cool to read.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it sounds like
you've had some success
as a futurist predicting
what's going to happen--
MARK ANDERSON: Not a futurist.
A predictions expert.
AUDIENCE: Predictions expert.
MARK ANDERSON: Very different.
AUDIENCE: So is there the
equivalent of the GFC coming?
Or are there any upcoming
economic predictions
that you've made that
may be negative for me
that I should know about?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah, sure.
And I'll just do
the drop thing here.
If you subscribe to SNS,
you get it every week.
But we've been working-- and
it's kind of a funny situation.
So according to the
Department of Justice,
we have a division which has
done the best job ever done
at describing the Chinese
national business model.
And China is so large and so
important in the global economy
that if you don't track China
pretty much week to week,
you're not getting
the whole story.
You don't understand
the global picture.
And we made a discovery, I
believe in January of 2015,
that based on some things
we were seeing inside China,
that they were having
economic problems.
And now it's three years later,
pretty clear that worked out.
That was true.
So if you were worried
about the global economy,
and you say, what
possibly could go wrong,
other than [INAUDIBLE] stuff,
one thing that could go wrong
would be that China
was in trouble.
And my opinion-- just
call it opinion--
is that they have been having
an economic downturn since then,
which is why you see their
national debt exploding.
It actually began
climbing before that,
but I think that's a
pretty good turning point.
So my prediction has
been that they've run out
of tools to contain this.
And that's a pretty
arrogant statement.
They have a lot of
tools, and they're
very good at containing
things, including information.
So it's a bit hard to dig up.
But you'll see things
that would reinforce
the case if it's true.
So as an example,
market manipulations
to avoid the outside world
seeing that the markets were
in bad shape.
They just pulled
six big companies,
they de-listed them a month ago.
They have others like HNA,
which essentially bankrupt.
So bank that said, we won't
give any money to HNA, they're
bankrupt.
Well, then the party
came in and said,
give them billions of
dollars, thank you.
They said, OK, we'll do that.
Same bank.
So these are unnatural
acts, on some level.
And I think that they provide
a floor for understanding
the prediction that we made.
And I don't know where
it's going to go.
But to the degree
that we're predicting
that the Chinese
economy is going
through some kind of major
problem that was not temporary.
It was structural.
That seems to be true.
So I think that would answer
your question, probably.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: It's one to watch.
One thing that
strikes me is, it must
take a fair amount of courage
to make a prediction that
is not what all the smart guys
in the room are saying, right?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Is that
something you've always had,
to be able to tell
some smart person,
or at least to be able to
put it out there and say--
because you often do it in a
very humble way, like maybe I
don't know what
I'm talking about,
but it seems to me x, y, or z.
But there's some
wisdom behind that.
But talk to me
about that process,
because I think
innovation requires,
often, everybody thinks
you're crazy, but you're not.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
Well, I'm lucky I now have
since 1995 to fall back on.
I didn't have that in 1996.
So that helps.
And you don't have
to state that.
People can just
go find that out.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
MARK ANDERSON: People
tend to think that they're
in an argument with you.
If you say something
that they don't like,
they want to argue with you.
And I never argue with people.
I just say, look, one of us
is right and one is wrong.
Tomorrow, it's either
going to be sunny,
or it's going to rain.
I'll predict rain.
You take your shot,
and we'll find out.
I'll call you tomorrow,
we'll see what it was.
So there's no heat in it.
There's no emotion in it.
It's just, either this
prediction will come true,
or it won't.
It's not a matter of conjecture,
it's just a prediction.
And I think that helps, because
it clears the air of emotion.
But certainly,
you can say things
that people don't
want you to say.
SPEAKER 1: I guess
also, just speaking
of pattern recognition
on pattern recognition,
you've been through
enough situations
where the experts
didn't have it right.
Or at least know that, what
are the chances that they could
be wrong, and I could be right?
Well, we have seen that
happen before, so at least
at a meta level, there's
some confidence there, right?
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
I was in a secret meeting
that I won't describe.
But we've briefed a lot
of three-level agencies,
[INAUDIBLE] agencies.
And a guy there who
was world famous
argued with me about something.
And I can't tell you
about the meeting,
but I can tell you what I said.
And so I said, I
think you're wrong.
And he said, well, I'm
right because I'm this guy.
And I said, well,
what are the numbers?
And I knew what
the numbers were.
And luckily, there
was one other person
in this fairly small
meeting who also
knew what the numbers were.
I said, your
perspective is wrong
because if it goes
the way I'm saying,
nothing bad will happen.
And you're really, really
worried about that.
It's preventing you
from taking action,
and you shouldn't be worried.
So I guess there's
one thing that I got--
I mean, I did have an argument,
but it was pretty important.
In general, the danger isn't
from Wall Street analysts,
or the hoi poloi, or all
the analysts in the world,
or economists pile on you.
They probably don't even bother.
They just say what
they want to say.
And someone has to weed
you out in the noise.
But there's a
different danger where
you say something that
makes somebody mad,
or you say something
which risks their company,
puts them at risk.
Not because you don't like
the company, it's just true.
You uncover a crime.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARK ANDERSON: I've
uncovered a few crimes.
I've had death
threats from that, so.
SPEAKER 1: Imagine if you
track flows of money and things
like that.
Sometimes you find things
you weren't supposed to.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
I actually did some
work a long time ago
that led to the first
imprisonment of officers
and directors in the
savings and loan scandal.
And I got death threats then.
And 5 million fines.
So it can be dangerous
to say things.
But I think you're right.
I have the personal view
that you're going to be OK.
I think courage
has its own reward.
SPEAKER 1: Mm-hmm.
And you're not doing it
with an obvious agenda.
You're just letting your
data go where it takes you.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
It's funny, people think--
since we all have agendas,
they assume you have one.
I do have one, tell the truth.
Predict the future.
That's my agenda.
During the first
election, I said
George Bush Jr.,
if he's elected,
will become the worst
president in American history.
And I got all this hate mail
from Republicans saying,
you are so biased.
You're a Democrat.
I tried to get it, it's like,
no, you don't understand.
I'm not at all biased.
I believe this.
This is going to happen.
And I think that actually
worked out pretty good
as a prediction until now.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I
was going to say,
it was looking really good.
MARK ANDERSON: Now I have
to rewrite it again and go--
but for a while, it
was a pretty good call.
SPEAKER 1: Any more questions?
We have a few moments left.
Yeah, go ahead, go to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
It seems like a lot
of your predictions
are around economics
and maybe politics.
Are there any other fields that
you focus on that are possibly
scientific.
MARK ANDERSON: Oh, yeah.
Many, many.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
to hear an example.
MARK ANDERSON: Well,
so health care.
Genetics.
We have a new
genetic theory called
equilibrium genetics that came
out of pattern recognition.
Physics.
So I've written a theory
called resonance theory, which
is based on the same thing.
It was probably one of the
two first papers that looks
like a string theory paper.
The first one was
finally published
by Michael Green back in '80.
I couldn't get mine published.
I had to publish it myself,
because no one would
publish my paper.
But it's still, I think,
as correct as it was then.
So there are a lots of reasons
people don't get their physics
papers published.
So I think it applies to
anything, any science,
doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
observations or predictions
over the housing
price in the Bay Area?
For example, I
live in Sunnyvale,
and the price basically doubled
in the past eight years.
A 1,700-square-foot home
with a 7,000 square feet lot,
the price goes from 1.2
million to 2.5 million
in my neighborhood.
I wonder, how much
higher can it go?
And meanwhile, when
I look all the stats
in the past few years,
for every five to six
to seven new jobs created, there
was only one new housing unit
being built. So clearly,
you see the pattern
of supply and demand.
But meanwhile, if I look at
the patterns in Chinese cities,
like Beijing and Shanghai,
1,000-square-feet apartment can
go as high as $2 million US.
By the same pattern, we
can argue, in the Bay Area,
the same 7,000-square-foot lot
can go as high as $10 million.
So what kind of predictions
or observations do you have?
MARK ANDERSON: So I think you've
2/3 answered your question
yourself already.
Certainly, tech has a
long-term impact on housing.
That's true.
Also, China does.
And so I would almost--
I don't know if you're Chinese,
but I'd send the question
back to you, which
would be, if I'm
right about the current state
of the Chinese domestic economy
and their troubles there,
you see the government trying
to squeeze lending a
little bit and reduce
the amount of lending.
You see people trying
to find the next place
to put their money.
They had wealth
management products,
all these different
places to put your money
to get a higher return.
Well, given that I think
that the Chinese market was
an important-- or Chinese
people were important players
in the Vancouver, Seattle,
and San Francisco real estate
markets, will the turmoil,
the internal struggles
in the economy at home,
cause them to do less or more
purchasing of real estate--
legally or illegally,
I don't care--
in the United States
in the future?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: 21 years.
MARK ANDERSON: OK.
Well, I don't know the
answer to that question.
But if we're going to
do a deep dive on that,
I would try to figure
out that answer.
Because it could go either way.
If they feel like
they're not being allowed
to find good returns
at home anymore,
they will probably find illegal
ways of repackaging money out--
which they've
already been doing--
and stay with the program of
buying real estate elsewhere.
If they feel as though
that's not the case,
then my guess is that as the
investing climate suffers
in China, they'll pull back.
And that will have
a dramatic effect.
When there's low inventory--
like you mentioned--
when there's low
inventory, prices
are very highly leveraged.
And it doesn't take
much of a loss.
A few percent
decline in demand can
create a very large
percentage decline in price.
So my guess is, probably,
it's going to be that one.
But we'll have to see the
answer to this first question.
I don't know the answer
to that question.
When I don't know something,
I love saying I don't know.
In that case, I don't know yet.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
You're making an
interesting point about,
that there's all these
interconnected forces that
aren't--
you talk about
looking in a silo.
You think, OK, well, what's
Facebook's stock price going
to do over the next
year, and what's
that going to do for
Menlo Park housing?
But there's obviously
these bigger factors
at play that might end up being
a bigger needle mover than
[INAUDIBLE].
MARK ANDERSON: Much more money.
Much more money, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, the
money has to go somewhere.
MARK ANDERSON: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, this has been fascinating.
I think we could obviously
gone on for twice the time,
but thanks so much for
coming by and talking to us,
and giving us all
something to think about.
MARK ANDERSON:
Denyse will be there
if you'd like to get a
signed book from Denyse,
she'll make sure you get one.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Let's all thank our--
MARK ANDERSON:
Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]